tiens vous êtes là bonjour combien du
pesto tranquille tu fais ce 30 kg et
olivier olivier debré ce moment tu tu
baises 25 kg lors d'une rencontre qui
durera cinq kilos de moins qu olivier
vivent dans les véritables combats
les boxeurs sont répartis en catégories
de poids direct et casimir
qu'est ce qui t'arrive qu'est ce que
c'est c'est moi
assez pour françois bonjour tu viens
assister à mon entraînement on entraîne
non mais enfin casimir casimir qu'est ce
qui se passe quoi avais tu n'es pas au
courant il n'a pas vu la fiche la cij
qu'elle affiche est là sur l'arbre ah
oui oui je la vois attend grand combat
de boxe
battling casimir contre killer du snow
mais ouais tu vas pas me dire que tu vas
rencontrer monsieur du snob points et
alors qasimi enfin tu connais l'édition
au coût de la boxe bat bien sûr en garde
les mains regarde droite
oui très bien gauche direct casimir qui
n'y a pas d'avenir et le jeu de jambes
mais youtube en jeu de jambes rivasi
vas-y regarde il est splendide
allez tout ouïe très bien terry
mirkazemi je vais revenir tout à l'heure
pour rien au monde je voudrais raté
seconde à part
oi oi oi oi messieurs messieurs s'il
vous plaît messieurs
alors allons messieurs et dames et
demoiselles messieurs pour le titre de
champion de l'île aux enfants à la
gauche
il est 19 68 kg à la droite est l'hymne
casimir 174 kg
[Applaudissements]
bon messieurs
allons-y un petit sourire s'il vous
plaît merci
ne bougez pas y ont la double en la
double encore un petit sourire s'il vous
plaît ne bougeait pas soyez sûr y est
parfait en la double
à sourire s'il veut un sourire et menait
6 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
tél aucun champion pas tous les immigrés
[Applaudissements]
autographes photos mais mais mais photos
elles seront bien quelle importance
de toute façon je ne me mettrai dans le
journal que les photos du super champion
bat pink azimi
[Musique]